and welcome to our webinar
uh simply learned webinar uh how itil
combines
with the four pillars of digital
transformation
our guest today is akshay anand who is
the product ambassador from axelos
we work with their partner people cert
who issues certifications for the
courses we run
and our host today will be pankaj kumar
patak
who is a product manager for our itil
training courses
first a few instructions on how to
operate
the webex controls mainly use the q
a function to enter questions for
our post and
speaker we will collect those questions
and address them in the q a portion of
the webinar
towards the end uh if you have a message
for
us during the webinar use the chat
function
remember to ask all panelists
which will let you get the message to
all of us rather than
just to me and
in each case remember to hit the send
button
i'd like to start with a quick
pull if i may
and
let's give a moment here
this poll is going to be on
how you're feeling today and what your
current job role is
one moment
i can see a few eager beavers already
starting to ask questions
yeah i'm gonna skip the poll because
i've had a problem setting it up and i'm
going to go
right back to
introductions so first i would like to
introduce takash
kumar patak who is our product manager
here at simply learn for itunes
and he will introduce
akshay anand
and onto patek yes
i get started thank you thank you very
much stuart for the introduction
that it really helps um so uh
good good morning everyone good
afternoon everyone good evening everyone
all right so uh we are here to discuss
about how itl combines
with the digital transformation let me
introduce you akshay
uh with us first akshay anand is the is
a product
ambassador at exelor so i was working on
the development on new
guidance and research within the iit
service management portfolio
he is also lead architect of icalco and
has
written guidance across multiple ideas
for
publications he previously advised for
200 clients
on how to improve their ideas and
capabilities
implemented tool sets such as remedy and
service model
and also held up global ideas of
activities
at macmillan publishing more recently
akshay has also focused on bringing
together agile development
teams and ideas and professionals to
address
right so actually why don't you say
hi to everyone hi everyone
great so uh before even uh jumping on to
uh you know uh talking about how uh
it'll be combining with the digital
transformation
i would also you know i'd like to know
to ask akshay that you know let us first
define what digital transformation means
in today's world because
we we keep hearing about digital
transformation every now and then right
now every every person has a different
different uh you know meaning of digital
transformation everybody
seems to have a different understanding
about the cell transformation for me i
feel
uh digital transformation is not only
about technology but it is about
the complete uh you know business
modeling aspect of it
but we would definitely would be great
if you can share some lights about
digital transformation
and what are the four pillars uh which
makes the digital transformation
okay sure uh first of all hi everyone
thanks for having me
um just a reminder this is an ama so i
do hope people have some
uh interesting questions it is after all
ask me anything
um so the best uh
explanation of digital transformation
that i've come across and one that i
subscribe to
is one proposed by a gentleman called
charles aroho
who's based out of new york he's been a
a long
time speaker on conference circuits he's
held several
positions of importance in i.t
management in general
to paraphrase him slightly what the way
he describes digital transformation is
that it's
a change to a business model uh in a
in an environment where customers are
highly empowered
um and one in which technology plays an
enabling role and i think it's really
important to
break that down so the first foremost is
a change in the business model
so this isn't just uh putting in a bit
of new technology
or even cutting edge technology to do
um you know eek out another five ten
percent
in terms of efficiencies you're
introducing a radical change to your
business model
and a business model is not just about
the tech it's also about
um how you go to market how you fulfill
custom demand
how you generate customer demand uh what
are the key relationships with
your suppliers and other stakeholders in
the ecosystem
what's your revenue model etc etc yeah
you know the business model canvas is an
excellent
framing device to think of what a
business model is so first and foremost
it's a radical change to your business
model
um and the second part is customers who
are highly empowered
now that empowerment can come in a
variety of ways uh you know we are in an
era
of uh social media and other online
outlets and so
customers who perhaps did not have a
voice before
are now finding that they do have a
voice they couldn't call out
bad behavior they can call out good
behavior that and that's one aspect of
it uh the second aspect is that
customers in a lot of industries are now
starting to enjoy
little to no switching costs
and that has a significant impact on the
business model
so i'll give you an example um i
probably subscribe to nearly every uh
movie streaming device and music
streaming device on the on
in the planet right uh if i can't find a
song on apple music
i'll go to spotify if i can't find it on
spotify i'll go to amazon prime
if i can't find amazon prime i'll
probably go to youtube and
it's it's uh almost certain that i'll
find it on youtube somewhere
um but the point is beyond the little
bit of time investment that i needed to
put in
um i had zero switching costs because
uh even youtube has a free tier spotify
has a free tier they all have three
tiers
um so customers are increasingly
enjoying
little to zero switching costs and they
can switch between providers
uh with relative ease than what they
used to have
and then the third part of that
explanation is that technology plays an
enabling role certainly technology is
crucial
it is the uh the channel the vehicle by
which you're delivering your services
whether that's
insurance services entertainment
services media services whatever
the product the software the technology
is definitely
a channel but it the technology in of
itself
has no value it's what you're able to do
with the technology it's how the
technology enables a service
that is important and a prime example
i'm sure everyone has a banking app on
their smartphone
in in this day and age the app in of
itself
has zero value the value of the app is
connecting you with your bank or your
financial provider
allowing you to pay your bills or to try
make a transaction or something like
that the
product is your channel to the service
uh the second part of your question uh
package was
around the four pillars now based on the
research that we've done
uh within axolos over the last several
years we've
studied not only the stories of
successful transformation but also
stories of uh failed
more important than it is uh starting
success uh right i mean there's
there's that anecdote from world war ii
where when when
um aircraft engineers wanted to find out
where they needed to add
uh extra armor to to the fighter planes
they didn't look at where the holes
were they were looking at where the
holes weren't as it were
um so we've we started we've done a fair
bit of research and we
came up with this model to talk about
the different aspects of digital
transformation
um and those different aspects of those
four pillars
are the customer and employee experience
because it's not just customer
experience that needs to change it's
also the employee experience that needs
to change
uh it's the organization's values and
behaviors
uh or if you will the culture
quote-unquote of the organization
it's of course the business model as i
just talked about and then of course
there's operational excellence
these are four different aspects of
digital transformation and
regardless of your starting point you
will end up touching on
all these pillars great great thanks
thanks a lot for
explaining about the definition of
digital transformation first
uh so actually my first question um now
we can start with the ideal part of it
is basically how how is
itl or itsm is combining with the
digital transformation in the uh
technologies
uh it's a it's a really good question i
think there's there's a couple of parts
of that answer
the first is we have to acknowledge in
many
organizations uh itsm is seen as a
purely
infrastructure or technical operational
capability
which could not be further from the
truth but that is the the reality of
many organizations today
and we see that uh such organizations
are facing a tremendous amount of
pressure
to quickly update the service management
capabilities but
the years of under investment if you
will are now starting to
uh you know pay off with with bitter
fruits as it were
um so we definitely see that a lot of
organizations are looking
at um trying to transform and invest in
their operational and infrastructure
capabilities
to elevate those capabilities so that
the other parts of the transformation
the business model transformation or the
cultural transformation of the cust
employee experience transformation can
therefore be transformed
um other organizations a smaller subset
i will admit
see service management as a strategic
capability they understand that
service management is not just limited
to infrastructure or technical
operations
but it is truly about managing the
service whether that's managing a
technical service managing a business
service or anything in between
and we see organizations now starting to
understand that service management
is a far more um
far more wide reaching discipline or
capability
which touches upon every aspect of an
organization of a service organization
from financial management to
portfolio management and project
management risk management and and so on
um
now that doesn't mean everybody in those
areas are necessarily uh
itil or itsm professionals but this is
about a
a cultural step uh a mind a mindset
a sea change in the mindset it's a step
in the right direction to understand
that
we are all service organizations and we
need to start
behaving in service oriented ways
regardless of which framework we pick
regardless of
how many frameworks we pick it's about
understanding that there are certain
fundamentals when it comes to
service management that is
really great to understand about how
this is uh combining with the
uh portfolios of digital transformation
now my next question is
what if we wanted to understand about
how ideal adapted to
uh evolving id and system practices
uh well uh that goes uh quite
far back actually to uh i guess 2016
2017 when we start first started working
on
the seeds of what would become idol four
um
of course the architect team that we had
in place
uh brought a wealth of knowledge and
experience to the table we all recognize
that
uh you know the the relative positioning
of
technology within a service organization
had been elevated
since idol version three was first
published back in 2007.
i mean it also was published back in
2007 we have to remember that the
the lead time for publication publishing
a book like this is
measured in years it's not measured in
days so
the the publication of a lot of idle
version three guidance was grounded in
what practitioners were
experiencing in you know 2004 2005
2006 and
uh you know we're talking about uh 13 14
years ago
uh cloud computing was just starting to
come about and be talked about
um agile had the agile manifesto was
only about three
four or five years old at that point um
so
whilst we now talk about these things as
everyday things
we recognize that there there's been a
see
a massive shift in how it and itsm needs
to work
because of these movements in software
development
in computational technology and and so
on
so when we met together as an architect
we had certain things that we had to be
able to solve for
we had to be able to show people uh show
ideas and professionals how to work in a
lean and an agile manner for example
now let me take a step back we had to
show its n professionals
how to work with lean and agile
professionals in other parts of the
business
to do that we have to figure out a way
to make itsm and itil4
what back then we called it idle x but
we had to make idle x
itself lean and agile so that was the
starting point of thinking that if we
cannot make
our own domain lean and agile we can't
expect
our practitioners to be able to work
with other practitioners
from across the organization at the same
time we wanted to make sure that
uh people who are picking up item four
recognize the value that had been pulled
forward from idle version 3 and 2011
certainly we didn't want to say that all
the investments in the past whether that
was training or certifications or
tooling or consultancy
we didn't want to say any of that had
been in vain and now they had to sort of
you know slash and burn everything and
start all over again it's all about
saying look
we need to evolve as an industry here
are some steps to evolve while
preserving the goodness of best practice
but also here's the way forward here's
where the the industry is headed
um so those were the sorts of things
that were in the back of our mind as we
started to develop
the the models um
you know the the lean and natural thing
i think to a large extent we have
satisfied is it perfect no but that's
that's also part of
idols4's commitment to its own continual
improvement
we are always reviewing the feedback
that comes in we're always looking at
ways in which we can improve the quality
of our
books our guidance as well as all the
other materials that we offer
um and you know if if any of your
listeners have
uh certain thoughts they want to share
based on the experience you know please
do pass that along
to us um the best address is ask
axelos.com to send an email in to say
feedback for idle development team
and just put down your thoughts we do
read each and every one of them we don't
respond to each and every one of them
because we get a lot
but we do read each and every one of
them um and and
a lot of times those those pieces of
feedback lead to a lot of interesting
uh discussions um sorry i could just
waffle on so
you know you need to just tell me when
to stop yeah yeah
so i actually remember when he said uh
when the seed came for the ideal for
back in 2016 to 17
and finally i think i tell four released
in approximately 2009
since feb 2019 when teleport was
launched
till now how do you see people reacting
and adapting to the itl4 versus ideal e3
i think the reaction has been uh
overwhelmingly positive
uh i know that there's some skeptics
back in the day but i think as they've
seen after
as they've digested the materials the
new concepts
they've come to recognize the value of a
lot of these concepts
um i've seen a lot of organizations who
are just have just been blown away with
something like the guiding principles
and they've made it a part of their
organization's culture or discussions
that we need to keep these guiding
principles you know focus on value
collaborate and promote visibility
um start where you are think it work
holistically and so on
i've seen a lot of organizations really
take to those
principles because those are those
principles about
about culture about mindset change it's
not necessarily
it doesn't necessarily lead to a massive
tool
shift project or a massive process
re-engineering project
but it allows you to start thinking
structuring your thinking in a certain
way
towards a you know in a certain
direction
and it allows you to bring the rest of
the organization along as well
i've seen a lot of i've seen a lot of
interesting things around that and
and we do encourage people to submit
case studies to us
uh we we've we've published a few case
studies recently there's been
uh cern which is um i've always forget
the acronym but i always refer to it as
the large hadron collider research
organization over in
switzerland um university of oxford i
think is coming out soon
um i think uh what else will be
published
last year we published spotify we
publish amadeus which is a big
b2b company uh that runs a lot of
airline
operational infrastructure um so we see
a lot of organizations starting to
really pick up on itelf concepts be it
guiding principles or that stream
mapping
or um uh use using the four dimensions
to think about how they
uh structure their their internal teams
and capabilities
so we're seeing a lot of positive
vibes and positive reactions coming out
now well got it got it so
uh it is happening both from the
consumer side of it the different kind
of enterprises and
they are just giving the response an
overwhelming response
right thanks thanks for that answer now
my next question is uh
what how one of what are the benefits of
applying ideal
best practices to digital transformation
initiatives
so the the well the beauty of
applying itil to something like digital
transformation is
that when you when you keep in the
forefront of your mind you keep the
concepts of adapt and adopt and
continually improve in the forefront
you will understand that itil is
essentially the starting point of a
journey it's not the solution it's not
the end point
but it provides you with certain mental
models and concepts that will help you
structure your thinking
structure your discussions and structure
your decision making
so um for example in
excuse me uh for example in the high
velocity i.t book
um we talk about uh kinevin i think we
also talk about ken evan and digital
mighty strategy book
um and canva is a decision making or
sense-making
framework um i'd encourage your your
audience to go
uh look it up there's a lot of free
stuff available on youtube
we also reference things like worldly
maps these are amazing techniques
out there which allow you to apply
start to apply itil uh or itsm
best practice but merging it in with
best practices or
frameworks that have emerged from other
domains so you're now starting to
look at your digital transformation
journey from multiple perspectives
you're using the language and the
terminology and
faith dimensions etc from item but then
you're
combining that with decision making or
sense making frameworks and techniques
from kanban lean agile kinevin etc etc
and that provides you with a
well-rounded perspective
um and that's how again remember adapt
and adopt continually improve idle is
not the solution until it's not the end
point
i think it's the starting point of that
journey
right right great so uh
i i think uh the the questions related
to this little transformation which i
wanted to ask i think i'm
having a hold of it and uh i'm getting a
few questions as well uh would you
do you think we can take a few questions
sure yeah
all right great so um i i have a
question in front of me which is
basically
uh regarding the itil4 book so the
question is where is the i teleport book
where in the itel for book can the four
pillars be found
the four pillars are not uh i don't
believe that in
any book they're they're uh they're a
construct or a framework by which we
talk about these things but i don't
think we've er
sorry i'm happy to think yeah
i believe we do reference it in digital
90 strategy now that i think about it so
the
the book that the the latest book to be
published which is
at this point less than a month old is
is where we we
explicitly referenced the four pillars
model
okay okay right so uh the next question
is
uh has come on from imran and that
how are the itsm tools getting evolved
example
bmc remedy to subscription models
uh it's a good question um all i can say
is look the the tools uh are managed by
their own
companies they have their own roadmaps
uh
uh to share the road
with anyone outside those companies
which is which is fair enough that's
that's product management 101
um having said that we've we've involved
a number of
um uh practitioners and architects and
experts from
various two vendors in the development
of idol four
and we will continue to do so um
they these some some people uh prefer to
be
um advising us or we consult with them
uh some folks have chosen to author for
us
some people have chosen to review the
materials and provide their feedback
um so the the involvement from the tool
vendors has been varied
uh in terms of are you certainly going
to see an idol for branded
um tool set i can't answer that
i don't we don't manage the tool sets
i understood i understood right so uh
the next question
uh this is a little uh interesting
question
uh it's basically uh from jethroviri
asking about
uh what is the difference between ipsm
and itil
okay itsm i.t service management is a
domain
which is concerned with the management
of
services uh which are either
supported by technology or wholly
delivered using technology there may be
technical services there may be business
services which have technical
underpinnings
but it is the management of those
services that we refer to
as itsm
itil is one framework within the broader
domain of itsm
there are other frameworks as well
oh that's great uh would you mind just
letting us know about what are the other
frameworks
the 97 there's there's several iso
frameworks
uh cobit for id governance uh
there's um let's see i don't know
whether you'd call
devops a framework necessarily but let's
call it a framework
uh devops agile these are also
approaches and frameworks within the
broader space of service management
yes yes great right that is great so
roy uh i have a question uh from royce
basically uh
he wants us to talk about more on the
spirit behind the case studies within
the
dits training okay uh any
specific aspect of it i i don't see by
any
specific aspect it's just that they just
want to understand about
you know spirit behind the case studies
i'm not sure
okay uh oh well i'll try my best choice
um so with digital id strategy we're
trying to reach
an audience who has a great deal many
years of experience more than your uh
than than many other
um candidates or delegates in an idol
class
i mean it says on the 10 digital id
strategy and so we want to reach people
who
um are operating at a much more senior
level
either leading teams or teams of teams
or who are involved with the
management of the service organization
strategy
um because of the seniority but also
because of the
subjects that we tackle in digital 90
strategy
we felt that a simple or simply uh
relatively simple multiple choice
question might not be sufficient and we
looked at ways in which we could provide
a much
more interactive um
conversational style of assessments
which is why we went to
the sort of group discussion type of
mechanism
now of course that doesn't necessarily
translate when you are uh
taking training from an online provider
and studying at your own pace and so on
but there are workarounds for that
uh but we try to create this uh group
discussion type of an atmosphere by
creating these case studies
now it's a very simple case study uh
there are three companies
uh there's a customer
of certain types of services there's an
incumbent provider of those services and
then there's a startup
trying to become a disrupter in that
space as well
in in providing those sorts of services
and we use this very simple case study
to explore things like
how you would apply the guiding
principles to evolving strategy
how you would use other idle concepts
and as well as certain concepts that are
described in the book that you will be
covering in your training
how you would apply them to this
fictional case
so that delegates have a chance to
experiment and explore these concepts in
a
safe environment um before going back
into their day jobs and then having to
apply this
in real life situations and that was
really the thinking behind the case
study method
got it yeah that really makes sense so
uh the next question is around
uh let me go through
it's about where is the training and
certification of itr core leader
digital and i t strategy convincing
i'm not mistaking it has already gone
live it has gone live the the
uh the product launched on uh september
the 26th
i believe yes yes that is correct
so i'll think of the next question which
has come from
us ashwini kumar talking about
ideal v3 books kind of start off with an
overview and expand of the process in
the intermediate levels
but ideal 4 looks different foundation
provides a very good
the overview of the guidelines and value
at intermediate level
though interrelated the book seems to be
independent of the foundation am i
missing something or how was this nvices
uh i don't think you could say that the
books are independent the foundation
they of course build on
all the basic concepts in foundation um
you know so you still see guiding
principles four dimensions
service value chain practices et cetera
et cetera
in each of the four books in managing
professional and certainly
in digital nike strategy as well however
where the
architecture of the books have changed
is that
the practices themselves which is what
the quran court processes of idol
version 3 were evolved into
the practices themselves are published
separately from the books
so whereas uh you could opens let's say
service operations and read
everything that there was about incident
problem request
access et cetera et cetera with create
deliverance support book which is
possibly the the nearest map that i can
mapping that i can provide in the create
deliverance support book you will read
about how to use
itil4 concepts to help them
to facilitate management of that
creation delivery and support
so you will read more about the
application of the practices themselves
rather than the actual details of the
practices the practices
you know again incident request etc
have all been published digitally
separately from the books
because we recognize that in this day
and age the practices themselves are
evolving
at a fairly rapid pace to publish it in
a book that perhaps didn't see an
update for let's say two years meant
that we
miss two opportunities of
at least two opportunities to update the
guidance itself because it would
involve a tremendous amount of uh change
to the books and
you know the stock of old books versus
new books et cetera et cetera
so what we did very deliberately is
within the space called myaxelos which
is a section of the axolot website
we decided to publish all the practices
in pdf format for now maybe that'll
change it later
but that will allow us to update the
specifics of the practice as
quickly as we need to having said that
there are certain
uh shall we say um constants
uh for each practice you know purpose
statement basic terminology basic
concepts um and something new that we're
calling practice success factors which
is
what needs to be done or what needs to
you need to be able to do
in order to make that practice
successful so for example with incident
management
for the a practice success factor for
instance management would be
the ability to detect incidents early
another one could be to resolve
incidents as uh quickly as possible
you know they're simple ones but these
are things that are success
that are needed in order for the
practice of instant management to be
successful
so when you go to the create deliverance
support book you will read about how to
apply incident management you won't read
about incident management itself
so the guidance has actually been split
across two different publications
and that's that's a change of the
architecture that people need to
understand
oh that's great i hope uh ashwini um you
got your answer
so the next question is regarding uh
it's from doris chia
can you advise in digital transformation
as for theses what are the best
questions to ask to contribute to the
transformation
that was not there before and one must
have in order to go beyond
general knowledge that was a long
question which and i don't think i
actually understood it so uh sorry
pankaj would you mind repeating the
question yes
yes absolutely the question is can you
advise
in digital transformation as for theses
what are the best questions to ask
to contribute to digital transformation
that was not there before
and one must have in order to go to
beyond general knowledge
i must admit i'm still struggling with
the question after you've asked repeated
it a second time
um look if i were a practitioner and i
was in a workshop to talk about my
organization's digital transformation
i'd start by asking questions like why
what is the impetus
to talk about digital transformation
because i would want to qualify what my
organization
meant by digital transformation did they
mean implementing new tools
do they mean developing
software quickly do they mean actually
changing
to
changing the business model itself you
use the word
thesis which is also intriguing because
i'm wondering whether doris
is coming at this from a research
perspective uh there's there's a fair
amount of research that's
already out there academic research
that's already out there
on this topic of digital transformation
but again i would still start by
examining whether you know what
percentage of digital transfer
successful digital transformations were
effective at changing the business model
how many uh what percentage of uh
failures
uh came down to uh lack of
organizational change management
or communication for example um
that's probably where i'd start the
conversation so i i apologize
doris i i'm not sure i understand the
question too well
um if you'd like to ask it in another
way i'd be happy to to take that up
again
well but but still you tried actually
answering that question as well
so i move on to the next question uh
which is coming from
mitra paul johan is basically uh
how can we convince the leadership and
customer
the benefits of exploring iti even
further as
introducing new modules possesses some
risk that always bring
reservation with digital transformation
customer is more looking
the things from the lens of technical
management
um it's a really good question certainly
uh
we need to be able to manage upwards uh
as we uh start to introduce or pitch the
idea of investing further in i24
um to my mind
as a as i think i mentioned before it's
about
re-establishing the fact that the uh
that your organization is a service
organization it's not a technology
organization
it's a service organization that's
trying to leverage technology to its
greatest advantage
and being a service organization isn't
just about
investing in technology it's about
looking at your end-to-end
business model or your operating model
and
um i would recommend uh to sorry i
forget
to ask the question um
okay uh i would recommend you go and
look
at a couple of um artifacts
that you can find online uh but are also
in the digital 90 strategy book
from idol 4 called the operating model
canvas and the business model canvas
and i would put this up in front of your
executives
as a starting point for a discussion to
say look if you're thinking about
uh changing the way we work for the
better
these are the different aspects you have
to think about it's not just about the
technology
it's also about the skills and the
competencies we need it's about our
relationship with our customers
it's about a relationship with our
suppliers it's about
um you know how we um account for the
work that we're doing and the costs that
we incur
how we account for the revenues that
we're making and so on
uh because the business model canvas and
operating model canvas are not idle
constructs they are
very well defined and established
business analysis
constructs or artifacts they come from
that world
and any leader in my mind any leader
what they saw
knows these two canvases and if you use
that canvas as a starting point to say
look
idle for talks about business model
canvas talks about operating model
canvas
talks about the need to change certain
things it provides guidance of how to go
about making those changes
what good might look like it is worth
our investment
that's possibly the the second way in
which i would
approach that question i think yes uh
now it's in metropol's hand to go
forward and take it ahead
uh moving on to the next question which
is coming from topic
is basically what is the best way to
start migrate from itl
v3 to itl4 inside our organization
excellent question um
i assume you're not talking about
certifications if you are talking about
certifications then there's managing
professional transition
there's a whole certification scheme and
i'm sure uh
package uh you and your team at simply
learn can can go back to
uh that person and and talk about the
something like migration absolutely
but i think this is more related to the
organization's perspective wherein they
are currently following the
itl v3 framework and they want to
migrate or transition to
phone sure uh so interestingly
one of the things that i or slightly
controversially i suppose one of the
things i i usually propose is that it's
not
you you shouldn't be sending your junior
staff on it for
first you should be sending your
managers on it for first
because you run the risk of
your junior staff coming back really
enthused and excited about the new ideas
and concepts and models
and ways of working introduce the night
of what that item 4 talks about
but they have no influence to be able to
change the way in which they're actually
able to work
so my slightly controversial suggestion
first
send your managers on the course first
let them come away with an understanding
of
the guiding principles and what it means
to focus on value
or collaborate and promote visibility
and so on
because they're the people with the
scope of control and the scope of
influence to be out to be
which will allow them to actually create
the change that people want to see
in organizations beyond that
i think there's uh that
i actually have an entire webinar on
just this topic and i'll be speaking
about it at
um it's mf uk later this year and
service management world as well
but very briefly in my mind there are
sort of three or maybe four options
the first is to start with guiding
principles so
as i said focus on value collaborate and
promote visibility etc
these are cultural changes which will
take longer
to embed in your organization but will
have a higher payoff
in the long term there's a significant
amount of costs and risk in the short
term but you have a significant upside
in the long term
the second option is to start with
continual improvement so give
everybody the headspace to be able to
you know take an hour away from work or
um every um
every week uh or a couple of hours where
they can work on something new
something that will help them do their
jobs better something that can help
their
team do the job better because that
experimentation that
sort of continual improvement will start
to reap dividends um
the further along you go of course
you've also got to be able to scan your
environment to say
are there any disruptors that will
massively change
what i'm doing because if i'm just
focused on the here and now and just
making small tweaks to what i'm doing
i might not see i might i might not see
those disrupted
coming in the third option is to start
with value streams and processes so
adopt techniques like value stream
mapping figure out how
work and information flows across the
organization from
demand to value creation um this is
something we
write about quite a bit in the create
delivery support book how do you go
about
designing or documenting value streams
use those value streams to identify
bottlenecks
use the value streams to identify what
capabilities your practices
need um so that you identify what
capabilities are extra
extraneous or wasted investment from
what you currently have so you can start
turning things off
um that way you become a much leaner
organization
so that's that's option three and option
four is to actually do all
all of those three simultaneously at
different scale different level
different time frames
but to try to bring about cultural
change
um invest in a culture of continual
improvement
as well as start to lean out your
practices by using value stream mapping
uh techniques um so that's the sort of
very quick summary of of the
presentation that i'll be doing later
this year
but it was a great question thank you
thanks thanks thanks a lot uh okay i
think
that would really help topic in uh you
know going back to the organization and
thinking about
how they can transition from v3 to four
um the next question is also in similar
lines uh which is basically
itl i followed it v3 curriculum ideal
expert level
how can you help us move to forward itl
i think uh
this is pretty pretty straightforward
wherein uh this is related to the
certification part of it and uh
you can uh you know take the ital for uh
mp transition module
to you know transition yourself from itl
vp expert to itl management professional
uh in the ideal forward framework so
let's move on to the next question
which is coming from akshay to akshay is
basically
uh though he wants to elaborate on the
difference between
ideal for mp and ideal for sm so
basically
he wants to understand of the difference
between managing professional and
strategic leader
okay and we need to follow which path as
well
sure um i'll i'll include foundation in
that as well because it
it'll help to paint the the whole story
um
item foundation is for essentially
newcomers to the field of service
management
now they could be fresh college grads
they could be
um senior developers or managers from
other parts of the business who are now
finding themselves in
a position which requires some knowledge
of idle and service management in
general
so foundation is very much that entry
level it gives you the basic
concepts terminology and so on managing
professional
is then for people who are designing or
managing systems of work
is a way i like to talk about so you
might be a consultant
you might be a manager you might be um
let's say an individual contributor but
someone with a wide degree of influence
and you might be
designing the way in which people work
like what are the procedures what are
the tools that are
what are the skills that we need et
cetera you might be designing that
you might be managing a team which
and therefore having to look after the
tools the skills the
funding the partner or supply
relationships and so on
so the the common thread there is
you are either designing and or
managing these systems of work and if
you're doing that then managing
professional
is something you should be looking at so
if your role
or if your current role is focus more
around
stakeholder engagement and management of
relationships and drive stakeholder
value is something that you should be
looking
if uh the currently you're trying to
solve challenges
around uh creating the appropriate
metrics
uh interfacing with governance risk and
compliance
[Music]
managing small organizational changes
then direct plan and improve is
something you should be looking at
if your role requires you to manage the
flow of work
across a team or several teams from
design work to development work to
transition to support and so on
then create deliver support is one is
something you should be looking at
and if you're designing or managing
service itsm
capabilities to work in a lean and agile
way
then and resilient and continuous way
then
high velocity it is something you should
be looking at so managing professional
is very much for those professionals who
are
designing or managing systems of work
strategic leader is essentially the next
step up if you will in the hierarchy of
an organization so
here we have very much more senior
managers
you're you're responsible for
business model uh uh manage managing
your business model you're responsible
for managing your operating model or
transforming your business model and
operating model
you might be having to undertake larger
programs of organizational change and
transformation
and if you're working at that much more
of a strategic level or starting to
move in in that direction then uh
digital like
strategy and the strategic leader
learning stream
is one for you so that's how different
learning blocks matter
great thanks thanks a lot uh akshay to
answer
akshay's question uh moving on to the
next next question
uh which is uh coming from doris
uh okay just a moment
while you read through that i did
receive a private question from signup
which is what does happen does jira
service now and other ticketing tools
come
under itil itsm so again itil is a
framework a framework is meant to be
adapted and adopted
it is a description of ways of working
it's not a tool or a technology so
uh you we can't say that jira servicenow
remedy etc
are idle tools they are i.t service
management tools
the workflows might be
aligned with what itel talks about but
they are itsm tools they're not idle
tools there's no such thing as an idle
tool there are itsm tools
all right so the next question is from
doris
and uh the question is around if we are
analyzing the
digital transformation beyond general
knowledge post provide 19
what we should ask ourselves as on
business strategy level
on which acts of research for any
industry
to study to go deep in learning
you want me to read that question again
please or if you could put it in the
chat then i can just read it quickly for
myself and uh yep okay
meanwhile i'll just put it in the chat
uh
and i mean while we can go to the next
question as well which is coming from
abhimanyu
companies get used to it guiding
principle then don't you think that will
affect
them in differentiating their
performance identity
uh no not at all
apple music and spotify both offer
streaming music services but they're
different brands they're different
products
the your your guiding principles will
help you create
value uh more consistently more
effectively more efficiently
better customer experience etc etc but
your
your competitive differentiator is in
the
service you're actually providing
so whether that's banking services
entertainment services whatever
your competitive differentiator is in
the service you're offering
not in how you choose to structure
yourself internally
i see you've pasted that just give me
one second
if i understand the question i think
it is where doris can do
further research to understand more
about digital transformation
beyond just general knowledge um
as i said there are a lot of um there
are a lot of academic journals and
publications
uh that you can find online um published
uh
through you know open journals or
similar
um there are some other frameworks which
i can definitely highly recommend
kinevin is one wordly mapping is another
there's a lot of
mass market literature if i can call it
that that i can also recommend for for
reading purposes
um a couple of my favorite books uh just
off the top of my head uh team of teams
uh unlearn lean enterprise
phoenix project of course uh devops
handbook
i haven't yet read unicorn project but
i'm sure it's fabulous given
who's written it um i'd also take a look
at
the science of service management
specifically
a series of papers around service
dominant logic
uh that were authored by two gentlemen
in the states i believe called vargo and
lush
so take a look at the the papers that
they've published under the service
science or service development logic
there's
absolutely fabulous reading
all right so um moving on to the next
question uh chef
um considering the time constraints
which we have uh there are already a lot
of questions and i'm just picking up the
best ones uh there's one question which
is basically
uh you know uh is about uh
is ideal more for technical use and to
gap strategy basically
enterprise architecture is something
which is uh
gilbert is asking about look at the end
of the day
every framework has emerged in order to
address certain
issues um that emerged
that that came about or were commonly
felt in specific parts of an
organization
um idol emerged to codify
best practice uh in the uk public sector
back in the late 80s and it was
the technology and operations of
technology in those days meant that it
was
very infrastructure-centric rather than
software-centric
um uh agile emerged
in order to understand how to develop
software
more uh that was more aligned with the
needs of the customers especially in a
fluid
and volatile environment devops emerged
to understand
how to collaborate and share and measure
technical matters
across the development and operations
divide or indeed how to break down that
development operations divide
i don't believe any framework can
claim to be the framework for a specific
topic
but different frameworks will have
different degrees of focus
across the the entire stack so
itil for example certainly has a
tremendous amount of focus in the
operational stack
uh relatively less so but still
important amounts of focus
at the tactical and strategic step um
a framework like um
let's say an approach like agile or
devops
has a tremendous amount of focus on the
software development
side of the stack they try to address
other
issues that software development teams
will encounter as they start to
work in these new ways and so you start
talking about
you know biz sec dev ops biz sec
et cetera et cetera you know the acronym
becomes longer and longer every time i
look at it because they recognize that
you know it's at the end of the day it's
one system and they need to
they need to provide guidance on how to
operate with other parts of that system
so i don't think it's correct to say
that idle only focuses on that
and this other framework focuses only on
that it's a degree of the focus
it's about the degree of focus that is
is provided
right thanks a lot uh for answering that
question uh chip uh the next question is
from venue
that as a pressure technical analyst how
do we identify our process
is applying ideal framework
my question is why do you need to apply
that why do you need to determine that
that that's very simply my question what
is the value in saying that this process
is applying idle principles or not the
question you should be asking yourself
is is this process creating value for me
for my team for my customers for my
other stakeholders if it is if it is
brilliant move on if it isn't why isn't
it
and if we want to improve it what
frameworks or best practice guidance
exists for us to be able to
think about how we can improve it the
just saying that this process is idle
compliant creates
no value it's it's just a check box
exercise
absolutely that makes to make sense uh
actually the next question
i'll just think of one more question i'm
not sure i'm running out of time maybe
stuart can uh
pitch in uh so the next question is from
muhammad why hasn't itl4 merged with
shift agile certification
uh agile shift is its own separate
product
uh within axolot it's managed uh
by another team who work very closely
with us we work across the different
product
lines um agile shift as i said every
framework exists
has emerged in order to address specific
challenges that are felt in
a particular part of an organization and
agile shift emerged
because there was a need to explain
the impact of agile software development
at or agile ways
of working in other parts of the
organization
that's that's why agile shift emerged um
it's not to say that it's completely
separate and
unlinked and not linked with item or
with prince2 or with
msp or princeton agile or any of the
other frameworks they are they are all
linked
again it's a matter of the focus and the
question that's been
that's being asked so i think um i'm
i have a few questions left but i'm not
sure if time will allow me
a steward what do you think so what do
you think we can
i i think you can go ahead uh okay
yes thank you let's just think of the
next question which is coming
from how shall we
connect the dots in terms of data
analytics
and itl 4 in any organization
and the second question which is maybe a
polar question is also i would need to
understand the connection between it
product management and idea
sorry the second question is understand
the relationship
between ideal poor and
i.t product management okay so
the first question was about data
analytics it is a very important field
we need to understand
um what the data is telling us
especially across multiple perspectives
and domains
and while data analytics is not
necessarily addressed as a specific
practice within itel4
this has now got me thinking that maybe
we should look at that
certainly different parts of idle talk
about how you would use
the data to make more informed decisions
direct plan and improve even talks about
the different
methods of collecting data whether
that's
automated tools whether that's surveys
interviews
et cetera et cetera again not all data
is
quantitative as in derived from tooling
a lot of data is qualitative and
anecdotal and derived from
narrative techniques again if you look
at the kinevin
framework they do stress on the
importance of narratives
as a way of uh you know things like weak
signal detection
uh and i think that's that's especially
important as we move to a highly
digitized and automated
uh environment um
so it's got me thinking for some longer
term maybe i'll come back in a year and
say yeah you remember the question that
you asked
well this is how this is the answer to
it now yes um the second question is an
interesting one the relationship between
idle and product management
um in itel4 we talk about product and
service management
slightly synonymously but at the same
time we
if you look at the four dimensions model
we see that there are different types of
resources that go into the creation of a
product or service
those those resources are people and the
skills
information and tools which may may be
products themselves
um partners and suppliers who may be
providing products themselves
and the processes and value streams that
you follow so
a product needs to be managed certainly
and there's a lot of great literature
out there around
it product management and product
ownership
um look at the works of you know roman
pinch
melissa perry some of the writings from
people like um
john cutler uh don reinertsen amazing
stuff
um but as i said earlier in my opinion
the product
exists to be able to deliver the service
the product in of itself the
functionality in of itself doesn't mean
anything unless
it's connected to a service in the
backend and so for me
a while yes absolutely the product is
absolutely critical your banking app is
critical for you to be able to
pay your bill but it requires that
service in the back end for
to actually pay that bill and so for me
that's a relationship between the
product and service the service is
increa
the actual point of value creation the
product is your channel
to access those resources that allow you
to create that value
thank you actually i'll take up the last
question of the evening which is coming
from anita
how ideal will be helpful or efficient
in consulting or
recruitment domain different question
it is a good question uh i mean we are
starting to see a number of job roles
and
uh adverts uh which are already starting
to reference item four
which is brilliant um and i think that
momentum will just increase over time
um over time more and more people are
going to be ideal for certified
they're going to have skills that are
more relevant for uh
it organizations of today and tomorrow
and we're going to see more and more job
roles that
specifically call out item 4
qualifications
um from a consulting point of view again
although although consultants and i and
i've been a consultant for many years
although consultants may brand
themselves as an itil consultant
really what they're consulting is itsm
and any good itesm
consultant will not only call upon itel
but other
frameworks as well that approach has not
changed
with the introduction of idol 4. that is
almost a universal approach to
consulting and
i'm actually now starting to think that
maybe i should do a podcast episode
on we axos now has a podcast and i'm a
host
i'm actually thinking maybe i should do
a podcast to talk about consulting in
itsm but my point is that
consulting in itsm has not changed just
because of the introduction of idol 4.
it's that's more like saying you know
um i now have leather seats in my car
you know the car is still the same it's
still got the same engine
you're still relying on on other
suppliers
to provide you with the bits and pieces
you need to run your car you've got a
slightly different experience
on uh related to one aspect of your car
but the car is still the car so
consulting is not changing just because
of idle flow
right right so actually i think uh with
that uh
i have tried to cover most of the
questions you know i have tried to cover
i think mostly 90 of the questions
thank you very much for answering all of
them uh the
kind of patience which you have and uh
maybe a few of the questions which were
not answered you think
you know i think stuart can help you
people to understand about
how you can get them answered so you
know that's that's all about from us
um so stuart you would like to do some
closing uh statements
did we lose start
unfortunately it was muted uh actually
if you'd like to take this opportunity
to
say your last closing words and let
people know how to get in touch with you
a couple of things uh on uh twitter i'm
at blowboy
uh which you can see at the end of the
um linkedin profile as well
happy to connect with you the audience
uh all i would request is if you're
sending me a connection request please
send a note
to say that you listen to this webinar
um
i get dozens of connection requests on a
daily basis with absolutely no context
and i reject every one of them so if you
want to connect with me please do
you know include a note in your
connection request to and mention the
simply learn webinar
uh so twitter linkedin are probably the
best places
if you have any other questions about
idol 4
or want to even provide some feedback
about what you've read or what you've
studied
please do send an email into ask
axolos.com ask
at axelos.com
thank you very much and i want to thank
pankaj for hosting and doing an
excellent job of moderating today
and thank uh everyone else here
for listening in i also want to do a
special thanks to people certain axles
for
helping with this webinar and partnering
with simple learn
and to let you all know our next
webinar comes up thursday of next week
uh in the data science domain uh ronald
van
world will be talking about where to
start your
career path whether in ai or data
science so
for those of you interested in data
science
please join us for those of you who know
people
are interested in data science and ai
please
feel free to share this information with
them
and again you can
also connect with simply learn our
social media channels
facebook twitter and linkedin
and this concludes the webinar today
again thank you to everyone
involved uh this time
i would like you to go ahead and log off
of webex and
have a great rest of your evening or day
okay everyone remembers have a wonderful
day evening to everyone
and stay safe
you